live
morning little past
morning slow start
today but we have some results to look
so that is
a 4 minute
solve without generalized Advantage
estimation now the new sweep cuz the
other one got
stuck we're going to see if this one can
match or not it's going to be the
question
but things are looking
good
so I got some good plans for today let
me double check to make sure
nobody's needing me on this
and it's nice that we have all this
stuff here
they uh there's some stuff on Pokemon
lately
oh no LM can play Pokemon what did he do
you have 500 billion parameters billions
of dollars
DM me just make sure this guy doesn't
need help right now and if not we will
be good to start on
stuff I might have to go handle a call
real quick okay I'll be right